when you hear something that sounds like
a gunshot drive guy ritchie's specific
style if a little bits good a lot of
it's even better on an imax screen
you'll get to see more you'll get to
appreciate more you'll see more of the
detail America is teaming up with Russia
things could get a little messy I've
been a great fan of his previous work in
his films he brought his very special
style of which in his humor to make a
film that is so entertaining and fun you
need to kind of bring that on set which
made it pray for us cuz we had an
amazing time working with him I work
better alone I worked with Rowan to
absolutely incredible worker a guy he's
very collaborative he creates a great
family atmosphere on set the environment
enjoyable his MO is if it's not fun
we're not doing it right guys such a
visual director the images are so
distinct in this film that you just want
to see it on that screen
nicely done the Pope chase I don't get
on imax Rome the Spanish Steps stuff
anything that's a cinematic and
picturesque it's gonna look really good
the sequences in the speedboat on that
Mediterranean ocean with the Sun setting
and you're going to the big island
fortress that'll look incredible it's
gonna translate them become even bigger
than the screen like that you're really
on a ride and you really like lose your
breath it's spectacular for a special
agent you aren't having a very special
day are you I max is the best way to
watch any movie that has ever been and
if you're missing out on it shame on you
how's that for entertainment
you